ego dissolving experience that's one you
know the drugs you do it most umph ego
enhancing right like coke yeah you're
the baddest mother he's gone man yeah
you know you've never had coffee I've
never had coke never never oh man yeah
that one I dug when I was in high school
my friends cousin used to sell it and he
wasted away to nothing him and his
girlfriend would hang out in the Attic
never come out they would just sell coke
and watch TV was bad like it was like a
vampire bit him and he came up when
she's getting that kind of vicious cycle
as a rat yeah yeah I saw you I ducked it
I ducked it early never did coke man was
the first time he did coke I don't know
I was kid 11 12 [ __ ] I get involved drug
the early in life wow that's crazy
11 12 yeah I was still living in
Brownsville Brooklyn when I first ate
cocaine Wow
that's a crazy um listen I would never
let my children have a ten-year-old
daughter and eight euros I would never
let them live the life that I live I
would hate that always fight for heart
never wasn't being environment I grew up
in yeah of course
well you know you have the benefit of
having gone through it you know no one
else could ever understand how how how
difficult any of your life must have
been for you it's got to be one of the
harder things when you did that
documentary it's a amazing documentary
when you're very honest you're very
honest and and you're very open about
all your experiences and the one thing I
took away after that like no one can
understand you could you could hear a
guy talk like this I could hear you say
these things I could see the videos of
your fights to see the videos your
experience but to understand the life
that you lived it's impossible so it's
just a guess it's like your guess for
someone like me from the outside it's
just really interesting looking I think
about this young kid from Brooklyn New
York comes to custom RL
at 13 12 you know you know something Oh
son I have a little self-esteem this guy
gives me this big [ __ ] ego you know I
mean I'm live but you know I live by the
rules of that ego and that's and I've
accomplished so much then a Dominator
ego yeah you're yourself Oh
destroying people yeah yeah this anybody
could be a lawyer to underpin them
staring you down this weird environment
growing up that way you know cuz we have
people we try to avoid fights you know
me Brian for my instance we avoid fights
just to be able to see what you do like
your UFC guy you're a fighter this is
what you do for a job a lifestyle it's
really bizarre you were getting positive
reinforcement from thinking like that my
first time in your life absolutely yeah
I never felt like that before we like
taking up a big drug of the lousiest
booming it felt like get him in there
everybody telling you great yeah you
know for the first time in your life
never understood that and you know what
else customer I used to do with me he
used to take me to a hypnotist he was
heading as well yeah nice to go in the
hypnotist motions
what kind of [ __ ] to them make you do
you know how they do it if you relax you
go under you totally focus on blackness
nothingness right you go under and yes
being the savage intelligent having no
animal just working you're gonna do this
you're gonna be a ferocious animal
you're gonna fight put both hands to the
body you lose your job you do this and
ferocious fashion and they speak taller
than me as I was younger and you were
like 12 13 years old wow so they're
putting you under and just teaching you
that mindset yeah whoa did he give you
any advice on how to shut it off no the
k13 make seven eight there's no time no
time I'm not gonna teach him the off
switch just hit the gas therefore the
word together asteroid these guys these
guys in our way of you know me greatness
glory it's one of the hardest things
that many fighters I've and that I've
watched over the years have the problem
of shutting it off like turning it on
and living like that and just wanted to
be a Dominator with
in learning how to be a father learning
how to be man my first my first lifetime
with children and stuff trying to do
this stuff man I felt so disasters you
know it was just um I had no idea what I
was doing to I had no idea who I was
what arena I was stepping into it was
just it was just disasters I find out I
spend most of my adult life now I'm
apologizing to my kids you know I mean
yeah yeah I can imagine we inflicted
horrible father do you think they
understand what the [ __ ] that you were
going through they understand like I
have no idea if I try to basically make
sure that part of my life is empty now I
live different life for my kids
Ryan family now yeah well that's
beautiful